i do love being a mom i think
having that experience with travis would
just be
incredible
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are still trying for a baby despite the
blink 182 rockers recent health scare he
landed in the hospital with
life-threatening pancreatitis
but a source tells e.t travis is in much
better health now our source says kravis
still have baby on the brain and want to
continue their journey to expand their
family together quote having a baby
together is still an ongoing
conversation but travis's health is top
priority
i love the idea of a blended family i
think that you know the more kids the
merrier meanwhile newlywed bliss hasn't
worn off for the duo we're told married
life has been amazing and the kids are
all adjusted and they are all living
life to the fullest
we're just you know living our best
lives and that's pretty clear from what
we can see courtney and travis had a
romantic getaway and did what they do
best
yep here's the couple packing on the pda
just outside of santa barbara with court
laying on top of her hubby in the sand
no doubt about it court and travis are
never shy about putting their love on
full display now this most recent
makeout went down in montecito not far
from where the rocker popped the
question back in 2021
the pouch founders shared pics from
their seaside getaway on instagram
and things seemed to get really romantic
in their resort room with rose petals in
the shape of their initials spread out
on the couple's bed and travis left the
sweetest comment under court's post
quote i never want to stop making
memories with you
i've never met
a better human in my life and while pda
is the norm for court and travis at this
point our source says her ex scott
disick is still getting used to
everything but respects their
relationship i think in the end it's
kind of a good thing i couldn't do the
job of being with her
so i salute travis like he's in for a
lot of work of course court and travis
were open about their challenging
fertility journey on season one of the
kardashians and though the odds were
against them they stayed the course
even though there's
only one follicle that dr wood is really
seeing that's like standing out the fact
that we have any just all gives me a lot
of hope we're hoping for the best in
travis's recovery and a successful road
to conceiving for kravis yeah i can't
wait
[Music]
you